foreign
this morning we continue our special
series and I mean special kindness 101
with Steve Hartman sharing stories that
are built around themes of kindness and
character and the people who have
mastered those qualities today's lesson
is in Friendship Steve and his kids
introduce us to two little girls who
prove the best friends know no bounds
and might even show up in matching
outfits
[Music]
good morning by now you know my daughter
Meryl good morning everyone today's
class is
classes and as always we start with your
brother Emmett at the dictionary desk
Emmett good morning I'm defining
friendship as a lasting affection trust
between two people who are usually not
related yeah a friend wouldn't harp on
you to unload the dishwasher or make you
eat your banana every morning a friend
accepts you exactly as you are no matter
how different you may seem to that point
I have a story I'd like to share it's
one of my favorites from the archives
because I think it captures the true
essence of true friendship
Miami preschoolers Gia cernicola and
Zuri Copeland say they're not best
friends I know they say they're closer
than that closer than mere sisters even
in fact Gia and Zuri truly believe
they're twins oh yeah Ashley and
Valencia are their moms they will tell
you that they are twins and they have a
long list of reasons why to back it up
to them what makes a twin uh
similarities similarities come here for
example the girls say their birthdays
are practically the same day and the
obvious physical similarities so what am
I looking at here the same height oh
because you're the same height clearly
twins which is why they also insist on
matching outfits whenever possible so
far Ashley and Valencia have indulged
them but they also recognize there is
some bitter to this sweet you know
you're happy for you know for a few
seconds and then you become sad because
they have to grow up and then Society
takes over
indeed Society already tried to take
over
Zuri and Gia were at a birthday party
when an older kid told them they
couldn't be twins because they don't
have the same skin color
Gia broke down but through her tears she
got out this rebuttal she said you don't
know what you're talking about we're
twins because we share the same soul
I just get chill bucks um so
I was just like thrown by just that word
yeah
obviously what Gia was trying to say is
that at our core We Are One
and when we look back on our years of
division and racial Strife it's
important to remember that while all
this was going on so was this
we have a lot to learn and we can learn
from children in fact the moms say they
already have for sure we've never talked
so much on the phone and that's what the
twins want for all of us to push back
against the cynics some girl
and
move on to the more important things in
life you know what we're gonna get today
and you don't oh
it's been five years since we first told
that story and no surprise here Gia and
Zuri are still best Twins and they join
us now hello girls
Okay first why didn't you let my dad
have ice cream obviously he doesn't need
it but I'm just wondering
probably because we don't want anyone to
take him because oh my delicious clearly
weren't trying to make friends with me
how old are you now
we're at nine years old yep do you still
see each other a lot yes 24 7. what do
you think is the key to staying close as
long as you have we communicate after a
fight and we always say sorry and I get
out and it doesn't matter which one says
sorry first but you should always
apologize how long do you think this
friendship is going to last for a long
long time
and if I came by there to see you again
is there any chance I could get some ice
cream or no
thanks for your time and for showing us
what a real twin ship looks like
you're welcome sweetie
lots of good advice in there but of
course the best way to get a good friend
or to keep one
is to be one
we'll see you next time and don't forget
to stay kind
[Music]
I was so excited to see them again Steve
you've got to give us a five-year update
yes it was so exciting that a they're
still friends and they're still in sync
may that never change and I love when
she said some girls said we're not doing
some girl she doesn't know you know they
finish each other's sentences and talk
at the same time but it's such a good
reminder kids don't see color that's
right they have to be taught that double
scoop of ice cream for Steve for the
story of the morning I loved it yes yes
yes yes that was awesome she and Zuri we
are cheering you on good to see you
girls good to see you you're